tom holland upped his bartending game  for uncharted even bartending for a  night at his favorite bar in london it  took a while actually and i took it  really seriously margot robbie worked  with a free diver to learn how to hold  her breath for five minutes underwater  for this suicide squad scene i was very  very pleased with myself olivia munn  learned some serious sword skills for  her role as psylocke in x-men apocalypse  john david johnson learned how to blink  walk talk fight run block and punch  backwards for tenant  michelle pfeiffer became deadly  efficient with a whip for her role as  catwoman in batman returns